君たちは子どものころどんなおもちゃで遊んでいた海俺はね
ブロックと6ストリー
それだけタブンネ子どものころどんなおもちゃで遊ぶかによってたぶんその人はどの
ような人間になれるか想像力とか才能とかあふれると思うんですけどもそういう
ひらめき
なんか答えてーするオボちゃんがありますよねこういう虫のおもちゃみたいですこう
いう虫を作れるんですけど毛髪このパーツがあるんですけど自由に組み合わせてなんか
作れるみたいでございますコース
すごいねのプログラミングみたいな恥ずかしいして分厚く的で虫を作るんですけど
パーツによって馳せるこそ変わるとそうすると自分で移動の仕方が考えられるんだ
ルートを作れるらしいですプログラミングロボってことですかねこいつを3歳から6歳
ですからねは市側がこの時はこんなことはなかった時代の進歩を感じるんですけども
取れ節句挙げてみましょう
うわぁこれが
うびっくりしたーー
ちょっとコーンされビックリさーん
ああああああ
ソウルせーなーもうベンツ入ってるパターンねえちゃでましてこの子ですねこれ良い
ですねからだから話せるんでしょ
こういう形でて usb のケーブルになってますねここにこれも全部
離れるですはすごいなこれで例えばこれをつけるとまっすぐ進むと
tuhan
1 o
5歩
[音楽]
これとこれをつけあとずっとグルグル回転するのかなあー
はーはっはっは
ほら話した
これで回るようになります思ったんですけどもハチ公のパーツしかないんですよ普通に
買うとか茶色のパッチがないので今回
ああ
そんな嬉しそうな音出さないね今回なる猫の虫さんが持つ分かってみました
これ説明中に乗ってるんでわからないんですけどもひょっとしたらと空この星38個
以上つけても動くんじゃないかと思いまして今回はもう史上最強にならない超ロングな
プログラミング妹しロボット作って男創造力あふれる子どもたちに俺は未来を見てない
んじゃ
なるべくもだろう3
たことのない超長いドリブルさんも誰も見たことのない超ロングプログラミングろーっ
と作ってその最強芋虫は今日僕ん家で派生版はずだちょっとえーっよ
ファイティングで全部のパンツが出ましたはてなおかしい18だからカナダのパート
だけで48発ありますでちょっとこの子が体になるべくたくさんのカードをつけて
いこうと思いますそれだぞまで取るのかなーっ8個しかないって書いてあるんでぜんぶ
つけたらそうなるのかって言われるとわかんない
プーッ人はちょっと右に曲がるパートだけつけてみましょうか
ああっ
落ち着けパパ
和める ko
大共謀
おおおおおお超
ひょっあって123456なりますまあこれからだこの先が行くかどうかで決まります
から8こいつはプログラミングできる日10日が
バーサー
ペットシッター
ああああああ
すごいすごい
はあああああ
うーん常にこのながないもんですよね今ちょっと外させてみましょうか
[拍手]
あてマジで凄いよこれだって説明書に何にも書いてないんですよ実際繋いでみたら
ちゃんと動きました
大抵月度残りのパーツも全部くっつけて48パンツくらいつけてると思うんでちょっと
巨大ない猛暑という作りましょう
あなた急げー
bap
なぜ的にはこれぐらいの長さになっちゃいましたこれ俺世界じゃ俺は全然長い四方で
ちょっとこいつを今から始めてみようと思いますでは早速つけてみましょう
青木長所
[音楽]
しかし等指定席立ってきいちゃんすべてのスイッチが入っております
えっ
みんな6に打っゾワゾともちょ
ジョジョ展よ
[音楽]
いっ
パイと言うけどちょっとうるさい開いてみるちょっと残念ながら小巨大な芋虫をつくれ
なかったんですけど28恋空で撮った
うん85以上ネット繋げたも動くって事はわかったなぁもうれしかったしつけて最後は
ですねまぁそこそこ仲良い音 c 4体をきれいに動かしてね最後地で移動が終わり
たいと思います
所前で最後もう一突破し15世
ん
そういう時てきた張るのもいい
ああああああ
[音楽]
ran
me
ん ne
あっはぁ